but the bengals have already decided to
add joe burrow to a very small category
of players who are untradeable
untradeable under any circumstances if
we take them at their word now
i think my whole point here is
he's not really untradeable even now if
he could be traded if someone offered
patrick mahomes for joe burrow you take
patrick mahomes and you run because he's
proven and because he's great joe burrow
may be proven he may become great for
now though can you really put him in a
category of players like patrick holmes
russell wilson aaron donald lamar
jackson maybe aaron rodgers especially
when you factor in the cap hit of guys
who would never be traded you can't say
joe burrow would never be traded or
couldn't be traded not yet can you
no i no you cannot but but but where it
gets interesting and i think becomes a
really good conversation is
it's the potential of joe burrow that
puts him in a class to go you're gonna
have to blow us out of the water with
some type of trade to get this guy you
know one mike like we've talked about so
many times we talked about it a lot last
year with kylo murray you know you just
don't want to be the team that passes up
that generational type quarterback and
then you know you're sitting there three
years from now going man we we missed
out on one of the all-time greats and we
thought he was an all-time great but man
we sold out for you know a few
underwhelming picks or a few extra picks
man why did we do that you know with
burrow i think the the biggest thing is
you know again like you said there's
it's a crap shoot i get that
but man there's a lot of evidence
pointing towards this guy could be an a
special elite type player so i think
there's that let alone i don't know if
we've ever come into a season with a
number one draft pick at the quarterback
position
with just so much things positively
pointing up in the upward direction i
mean come on the year he had the way he
played the plays he makes 15-0 and the
sec
beating the you know the kings of
college football in alabama and clemson
and doing it like in style and fashion
like with major sex appeal you know that
to me
is where yes he's become very special
and almost a can't miss a prospect that
way and i just think the hype and
everything around it
makes him you know i don't like you're
saying he's not untradeable but he's
special
mike like who is the number one pick
that's coming to football that's been to
me
this hot of a commodity you know maybe
andrew luck and peyton manning to me
this is the first two in a long long
time
mike vick felt that way and he was
tradable he was traded the chargers
traded that pick to the falcons right i
guess the point is the idea that that
they are saying we weren't going to
trade that pick no matter what it's just
one of those things that bugs me because
i know it's bs
of course you would have traded the pick
if offered enough there's something out
there you know the saints offered and
ultimately gave up all of their 1999
draft and two picks the next year to
move up just a few spots to get ricky
williams mike ditka decided i'm getting
ricky williams period no matter what i'm
getting this guy and and if stephen ross
was bound to determine to get joe burrow
and he had three first-round picks this
year plus you can go out two more drafts
beyond this year and what you give up
you can give up five first-round picks
you can give up all your second-round
picks for the next three years you give
up all your picks the full draft for the
next three years at some point
that extra little pick you put on the
pile is going to cause the scale to go
that way it has to as something less
than all of the dolphins draft picks for
the next three years 2020 2021 2022
would have gotten the bengals to say yes
and if not they don't know what the hell
they're doing chris whoa maybe yeah i
know maybe they don't know what maybe
it's evidence that they don't know what
they're doing that was one of the
concerns sorry bengals fans because that
was one of the concerns that i heard in
the days preceding the draft that will
the bengals know what's good for them
will they get an offer that they
should accept
and will they know
that they should accept it and i don't
know that it got to that point because
we don't know what they were offered
well mike first off i think you're being
a little too literal yeah i mean yes
like i if they asked to go five
first-round picks i think a lot of the
people we talked about on this list that
are untradeable might be tradable other
than patrick mahomes if it came down to
like five first rounds there's only four
people on the list
well yeah so here yeah aaron
deshawn watson and russell wilson they
might become tradable
lamar jackson you know you think they're
maybe
probably not probably not because they
built the whole team around his skill
set on the offensive side of the ball so
you're right that would be a tough one
to pull off because there's just not
that many lamar jacksons out there to
run that offense but you know i think
the point that we're hearing with the
bengals and anything else is that they
were very sold on the prospect and yes
you're probably right if there was some
sort of new orleans saints type trade or
something like that i i don't think
they're that stupid i think they would
have done it i i do but i think they
also saw a guy have a special
i'm calling them out for being literal
i'm calling them out for painting with
this broad brush and puffing their
chests out we weren't gonna take any
trade for joe oh crap i almost said the
word you said last week
that was close yeah of course at some
point that's my whole point don't give
me this routine that you were firm and
you were set and there was no way in
hell you were going to trade that pick
if somebody had offered you five first
round picks you would have taken it if
andy reid had decided that joe burrow is
going to be better than patrick mahomes
within the next year or two and offered
patrick mahomes you bet your butt that
the bengals would have taken patrick
mahomes so that's my point don't don't
give me this tough guy football guy we
weren't trading him stuff it just some
things like that bother me am i wrong to
be bothered by that maybe i am i i get
it i i get i get what you're saying
you're right they came out with a strong
strong comment and maybe didn't need to
go quite over the top that way to to
prove their point to say that basically
we were really sold on this guy we've
been blown out of the water by what we
saw in the pre-draft process and we were
blown out of the water by what we saw on
film and how he competed and played
against the best teams in college
football the tougher the situation the
better the teams the better joe barro
played then you know yeah to me this is
this is a quarterback coming into the
league like i said with about the the
cleanest slate highest marks i've seen
like there was no discrepancies this
year we've had other drafts right you
know kyler murray no but even with the
draft with mahomes people we don't know
who's the number one quarterback is it
watson is it trubisky is it mahomes oh
there's always debate the last two years
there's been no debate at all we know
who the number one guy is and burro to
me is coming in with the cleanest latest
since like like i said andrew luck or or
peyton manning to where people just go
oh this is gonna work it's a slam dunk
he's the number one quarterback on the
board
and for now we don't know what the
dolphins offered the bengals and neither
team has any incentive to leak it for
now right time may cause people who know
whether they end up leaving their job
with the bengals or the dolphins or if
tuatanga viloa ends up being great and
joe burrow ends up stinking maybe the
dolphins will have an incentive to kind
of puff their chest a little bit and say
hey look look at what we offered the
bengals and we you know thank god they
said no or if it flips around if burrow
is great and tua isn't any good and then
the bengals can say hey we resisted and
we rejected this that or the other thing
from the dolphins but uh one of these
days we'll know what the dolphins
offered but clearly it wasn't enough to
get the bengals to say yes but i think
something out there could have been
offered to get them to say yes that's
the whole point they would have said yes
or should have said yes to something
they just didn't get anything that
caused them to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports